the Dominican Army tends to come in the
night Tatiana tells me looking for
Haitian migrants like herself
down the door and if they see things
like the cell phone they just take it
she's seven months pregnant but most
nights she leaves her rented room and
hides in this field fearing she'll be
deported back to Haiti once they almost
caught her
they came and I ran and I fell over now
I have to sleep in the open I can't
sleep inside
multiple Haitian migrants in the
Dominican Republic told us the same
thing that security forces come for them
in the night to take them away
quotations were happening anyway but the
last week has brought more tension the
Dominican Republic has closed the border
with Haiti over a water dispute
eliminia has been here for 24 years she
has papers unlike Tatiana but she says
even that doesn't protect you
they don't ask you for your documents
anymore if you don't have the documents
they take you away if you have the
documents they take you away anyway
many Haitians are now leaving
voluntarily packing everything they can
and heading back to their country one
controlled by gangs and in which more
than half the population is in danger of
starvation
even with the Border closed Dominican
forces allowed that one-way traffic this
is what we've been seeing in the days
since we've been here Haitians streaming
across the border from the Dominican
Republic going back home and we've been
told that this number of people leaving
on mass is highly unusual here as is the
security forces approach says father
Oswaldo Concepcion who heads a human
rights organization at the border
it's the first time that the Haitian
Army's been breaking into people's
houses and that there are mass
deportations it's an explicitly racial
anti-haitian discourse from the
Dominican president and he doesn't
recognize the work of Haitians in the
Dominican economy
we asked the Dominican Army and
immigration Ministry for comment neither
would speak to us but president Luisa
benader has made no secret of his
Hardline approach since he was elected
the Dominican Republic won't just
continue the deportations it's going to
increase them
[Music]
Dominicans support that some film
migration leads to Crime others that
it's simply out of control
meanwhile Tatiana is packing she says
that she can't spend too many more
nights in hiding she's ready to go home
John Holman Al Jazeera partido the
Dominican Republic
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera